hey everybody i'm jonathan trance and
today I have another tactical challenge
for you so when you see the image on
your screen pause your video and good
luck solving today's challenge today's
game comes to us from Carl Schechter vs.
Phillip mintner it was played in 1899
and at this moment go ahead and pause
your video and see if you can find the
winning continuation for white the first
move in this combination is perhaps not
that hard to see the black king is
obviously a little offside maybe we can
somehow get a mating net going so the
first move is g4 check ok and in this
game black took and the way white takes
back here actually matters quite a bit
so see if you can figure out the
difference between taking both ways the
correct way of taking is with the H con
and as we'll see white in some lines
needs that at 3 pond to be there to
shield against some checks that black
might have all right so the black King
obviously has to step up and now here is
the truly beautiful part of the
combination so if you if you feel so
inclined pause your video and see if you
can figure out the winning plan here for
white so white here has a fantastic move
and that move as Queen takes h6
which leaves the Queen to the other side
of the board what is the point of this
Queen sac
well now white has a very strong move it
will force checkmate in a couple of
moves King to h2 and the threat of
Bishop to f2 will determine the game
black can only last a few more moves so
you can play 93 and give up his knight
but he will soon be facing a checkmate
all right I hope you guys enjoyed that
video let me know in the comments below
if you're able to get that one right as
always hit like share subscribe we'll
see you next time for another tactical
challenge